we've done the five thrusting movements
now and uh started on the
the strikes so the strikes are
quite simply just because you're using a
joe
it should be the same as using a ken
so xiaomi komi was the first one
or number five
so if you do you can do the ken first of
all then you
can do this one if you've got
the chance to use the terra nucci the
tyre or bundle of sticks
you need something that gives you a
bounce and with the taranuchi we
we hold our hands at the end of the can
normally and it's a larger can it's a
suburuto
and the idea is you hit the tire or the
sticks
and you get bounce and you have to stop
the bounce
so it hits the tar and you and you stop
about five centimeters seven centimeters
above the tar
so you actually stop the bounce you
don't stop hit the tar and
let it bounce like this or you don't hit
the tar
and keep on the tar you hit the tar and
you
use the bounce okay so this is quite
important for the next one
when zakuchikomi what's a double cut
you need to learn how to receive
from the attacker receive use their
power
so with the taranuchi you you use the
power of the bounce
and when it bounces you learn to stop it
and this develops the stomach muscles
and the coq your breath and you stop it
i hate
and you do it by pressing a small like a
knot
in your stomach it's not a tense not
it's just a
quick key eye
pressure in the stomach hey
so the bounce it the part i'm talking
about is it's important about the bounce
so we've done the
uchikomi and now the renzoku economy
the same thing we strike
and the bounce this little bounce
we use to do the second
cut
okay so i'm going to use that bounce if
if i don't use the bounce it becomes
mechanical
and i'm doing all the work and this is
not our sense as i could own
we shouldn't be using physical strength
we should be using the flow
the natural flow of what we're given and
we're given the bounds
i'll try and do it slowly
please watch the feed this time
so timing is everything the passes
and minuses it's the pros and cons as
with the other things
so this may happen
you want to push out with your left hand
in a
the other hand is like a pivot
if there's a pin through here it'd be
like a pivot
so this hand is really quite loose it's
allowing the joe
and it's just following just following
the joke
it's not lifting the joke so
the fault here is some people start to
do this and then they start to lift
with the right hand this is a this is
incorrect
you push to the left
and then together they it comes up
push with the left
now this is running out of steam this is
running out of
distance so now it's time to come
together
as with the first one you look down the
side with one eye
down the side of your
strike you do it slowly you have to put
the bounce in
don't wind up the body this is another
fault
a lot of people they wind up the body to
get this second strike
to have power you don't want to wind up
the body
another fault that comes up
drop the tip now that
there's a moment where it might sag and
you have to mechanically lift it up
you need the timing to drop the tip and
lift at the same time
so that the dropping gives the top
momentum
so it's like
then you need the timing to get that
front foot
in time with that spiraling
cut
[Music]
not this
not this winding up of the body
the the turning of the foot is very
important with the turning
about here about here
that last quarter
is when the foot engages with the timing
of the joe
if you're going to do hypogeary with the
ken or
hypogeary striking with the joe you need
to understand about the timing of the
football
when is the time to engage the foot with
the jaw
if you have objects around you then
you're going to have to modify
things but try not to let it disturb
your
timing too much don't don't put all your
emphasis on the item
and lose what you're doing so if i'm
going to
miss miss the tree
[Applause]
i just take it out i don't
i know it's there
so the fifth and sixth
uh meant are
really just striking apple gear is
there and you can do this with the ken
or joe
okay so i hope you found that help
don't move